I Dunno if kids have changed or whatever.
Now they haven't changed.
They just think that this is the
thing to do. Now, look, when I was in,
when I was doing college is way back
in the day, I was in my twenties,
I did a college in Connecticut.
And right after I did the call,
I was talking to the kids. I would
do, I would do my set and then, uh,
I would like open up for Q and a yeah.
Fuck's going on my throat.
But it was,
um,
I was probably 23,
four,
25, maybe, maybe 25 at the oldest. So I'll
just, a couple of years older than them.
And so it was fun for me to talk to
them about what life is like when you
actually have to pay your own bills
and you're out, you're out free.
And some guy goes, uh,
you know, you got like,
I was doing the question thing and
some guy goes, uh, I go, you know,
I, I lift his hand to be able to tell a
joke. I go tell a joke and I go to Jews,
walk into a bar, they buy it.
It's an old fucking street.
Yeah. Street joke after the show, you
know the show goes great. I say thank you.
I really appreciate you guys coming out.
It was really a lot of fun. Thank you.
Good night.
So afterwards I was hanging around and
say hi to people and there was no picture
taken back then cause he had
to have an actual camera.
Then we had a fucking camera. It was
a long time, long time ago. This is a,
I'm 51 so this is a 90 91
92 somewhere around that.
Um, so this one guy
comes up to me, he goes,
the joke you said about Jewish people's
very offensive and I thought he was
joking. I go, are you serious? I
think it was, yes, very offensive.
And he's like nervous and shit and like
it has a hard time looking me in the eye
and I go, dude, I could think
about what the joke says.
It's about Jewish people being really
good at business. You walk into a bar,
they decided to buy it. It's such a,
it's nothing offensive about it at all.
You know? It's crazy. It's like it's
like people now and maybe forever.
I've always heard shit
and they immediately think
this means if I'm thinking
something bad about this,
that means that someone is
saying something bad about it.
They decided this is a taboo subject.
Even if you're not even say
anything negative about it.
Like say if you do a joke
about interracial relationships
or interracial race,
you just say it.
If you just do a joke about that,
there are people that are going to
put red flags up instantly and look to
misinterpret anything that you say
on purpose because they don't want,
they don't want that thought in their
head. They don't want the thought of,
you know,
like this guy's looking for antisemitism
in that joke to Jews walk into a bar,
they buy it. There's nothing
there. You could look all day long.
It's a joke about Jewish folks buying
stuff, right? It does. It does.
Nothing negative or a positive stereotype.
It's like a big Dick Black Guy,
Joe. It's not negative. There's
nothing negative about it.
Nobody gets upset that you
think they have a big deck.
Plus they have a little deck.
It's a lot of lead time. It's,
it's young people that also flexing,
right?
They're free from the control of their
parents and I find them you dealing with
that more in like rich or upper middle
class families because I think they're
more hands on with their kids and more
controlling and those kids get free.
They want to exert their own freedom
and when they get free of their parents,
they want to establish that
they're different and that
they have their own mind,
their own,
and then we're part of the new generation.
The new generation is not
going to tolerate racism,
CIS Hetero activity and they just decide
that they're going to fucking put their
foot down. But it's a pattern that repeats
itself over and over and over again.
It's just today they have social
media and this is the difference.
The difference is they feel like they're
empowered because they get online and
other morons that are the same
age as them. Confirm with.
You can just confirm any
belief that you want.
Like that's another lesson I've gotten
from this is just like confirmation bias
is like the wildest shit ever.
You can, you can be like,
there's one lady who wrote some Shit, I'm
anti gay, anti black and other people.
Yes. I'm like, yes, this is clearly, this
is clearly what he was saying. I'm like,
what that you took that from my set.
Me,
I'm anti gay and I don't think
there's a solution here. Yeah,
I've looked at this heart for a long time
now. We need safe spaces for comedians.
Just no solution because you're dealing
with immature people in terms of like
the literally the development
of their frontal lobe.
They're not fully formed yet. How much do
you think of it is like I put it in my,
the op Ed that I wrote,
but it's like,
I was thinking about like how much of it
now as a function of the fact that like
we immediately get whatever we want
in our hands. You know what I mean?
Like those instant gratification.
So it was like instant kind of thought
process where there's no real thinking
that occurs. It's more just like, this
comes into my brain. I hear gay black,
it has to be, this is
wrong. It's coming out.
Yeah, for sure. I mean,
if you say gay black on stage
today in a really liberal,
very progressive environment,
you get this thing you,
but you have to say something like pro
super pro gay and super pro black and it,
it doesn't even have to be
a joke. Right? Like get,
you're better off just going
for that applause. Break, move
comedian. I mean, people want,
people want their comedians
to be their leaders.
That's what, that's what it feels
like when it is one a laugh. No,
people, when I say people, I mean like
this next group of, uh, of comedy,
like of the people that were at the shop,
because the comedians that are going to
be their leaders aren't even gonna be
funny. They're gonna fucking
die to starve to death. You get,
once you get out in the real world, fuck
man, if you're not funny, you're fucked.
Yeah. Nothing but like, it's like,
like if I went up there and I said
Asians other shit and fuck Whitey,
I would've been, I have been the out
on the fucking chairs. They were,
they're going to carry me out
like this is all mother fucking,
you know what I mean?
But like that's the thing I think like
people like I'm not a hero man. I'm not,
I'm just trying to be heard, you
know? Well, your comic. Yeah.
Not trying to be funny. Yes.
That's all it is. This is, uh,
I really believe that this is just a
symptom of growing up and you're just
giving these people the power to
express themselves where there's,
there's no mature, wiser person
that's around them. It's his, hold on,
let's look at the context
of what he's doing. Right.
Let's examine what he's doing and then
you're going to apologize to him because
this is clearly a fucking joke.
You hired a guy to tell jokes.
He tells jokes and you say, not
that chuck, this specific thing.
It's strange because there were like,
everyone's like,
he did not respect what the event
was. I'm like, Hey. I'm like,
what? I mean, I'm not this, I'm not
your mascot here, right? I'm not,
this is not a pep rally dog.
I'm here to tell jokes,
but you weren't hired to do a
speech about this event. I'm here.
Did he rack my fucking act?